near the end of last year riven was the
third most valuable automaker in the
entire world only beaten out by toyota
and tesla this means that they had a
higher evaluation than volkswagen
daimler general motors and ford at the
time their market cap stood at an eye
wad range of 161 billion dollars and
it's not like they were delivering
millions of vehicles every single year
in fact they had just started delivering
their first production vehicle the r1t
since then ravion has produced and
delivered a few thousand vehicles
throughout q1 but this is obviously not
enough to justify a 161 billion
evaluation either fortunately though the
stock market has cooled off quite a bit
since the end of last year which has
annihilated rivien stock
in fact their stock graph is literally
just a downward trend having sold off
nearly 90 percent from the peak at the
bottom riven stood at a valuation of
17.3 billion dollars which is a far more
reasonable evaluation for an
up-and-coming eb startup but rivien is
by no means out of the woods yet and
it'll likely take years for rivien to
live up to their all-time high valuation
so here's the biggest issues plaguing
rivien and why this dog remains risky
despite having sold off 90 percent
rivien has been around for quite some
time having been founded in june of 2009
but don't kid yourself into thinking
that they're a mature company by any
means
developing producing and delivering
vehicles is an extremely long and
tedious process so even though rivien
has been around for 13 years they're
very much still just a startup not to
mention ravine has taken it pretty slow
themselves for example tesla was founded
in 2003 and they started delivering
their first production vehicle in 2008
so about five years later meanwhile it
took rivien 12 years to start delivering
their first production vehicle the
bright side is that rivien has been able
to perfect the r1t before launch but
from an investor's perspective if it
took them 12 years to deliver their
first vehicle how long do you think
it'll take them to launch cheaper
vehicles and scale up production
historically this wouldn't have been
that big of a problem because it's not
like ev companies were facing that much
competition 10 years ago but today
legacy manufacturers such as volkswagen
ford and even gm have been taking ebs
quite seriously in fact bloomberg is
predicting that volkswagen will overtake
tesla and ev sales by 2024 which is only
18 months away they also think that gm
and ford will roughly reach 1 million eb
sales each by the end of 2025 so rivien
is no longer the second biggest eevee
company like they used to be back in
2018 it used to be tesla rivian and some
chinese players but that was pretty much
it
now legacy players are not only taking
eevee seriously but they're even
catching up to tesla something else to
note is that gas prices are going
through the roof right now standing at
nearly five dollars per gallon this is
no doubt terrible for everyday americans
but for upper middle class americans who
have money it makes more sense than ever
to go electric and that's probably what
they'll do over the next few years but
the problem is that ravion isn't here to
capture all this new demand
i mean what do you think is more likely
an american family buy an ev that's
already on the market or an american
family putting in a pre-order for a
ribbon suv that'll hopefully be
delivered in four years i think the
answer is obvious ideally rivien would
have already had significant skill like
tesla by the time that eevee adoption
became more prominent but it doesn't
look like rivienne is anywhere close to
this goal given that they produced just
2500 evs last quarter to put that in
perspective volkswagen produces more
cars in two hours i'm not mentioning
this to just put down ravion rather i'm
trying to show what they're going up
against and why it's going to be such an
uphill battle for them moving forward
they really are just a startup that's
fighting against dinosaurs this isn't to
say that riven can't build up their own
niche customer base but it does look
like riviera missed out on the golden
period
a few years ago if you wanted an eva you
really only had one choice by tesla and
i suspect that rivien was hoping for a
similar position within the pickup
market if you want an evie pickup you
have to go with ravion this would have
given them significant exposure and
demand but the f-150 lightning is
already here which will likely stifle
events demand significantly and as more
time goes by it just becomes more and
more likely that the dinosaurs squash
riven
having to fight the legacy automakers
head on it is already bad enough but
rivian has to do that while also trying
to scale up production and based on
tesla's experience with scaling
production i think it's safe to say that
skilling it is by no means an easy feat
i mean scaling model 3 production nearly
dropped tesla into bankruptcy and
ripping it is just now starting to scale
up production riven does have some
pretty ambitious targets when it comes
to scanning production in february
they're hoping to get to 150 000 evs per
year by 2023 but honestly this isn't
that realistic after current rate of 2
500 eb's per quarter we're looking at an
annual production rate of about 10 000
vehicles even if we give them the
benefit of the doubt and call it 20 000
vehicles but basically where tesla was
at in 2013 and it took tesla for years
to go from that to represents goal of
150 000 evs per year so realistically
it'll probably take rivie until at least
25 to reach its numbers a bigger concern
however is whether rivien will even have
enough demand to produce so many
vehicles right now vpn has 71 000
pre-orders and this number will likely
only grow as more people start trusting
the company but these are the easiest
orders to get because all of these guys
are eevee enthusiasts who are willing to
wait a year to get an ev pickup as
rivien burns through these orders
however it'll likely become a lot harder
for them to garner our sales given how
expensive their vehicles are the r1t
starts at 67 500 while the r1s starts at
72 500
these prices make their vehicles
completely inaccessible to the vast
majority of people
now of course vivienne has orders from
amazon as well but i don't think serving
amazon is their long-term goal
their long-term goal is to become a
premium ev company but the only reason
tesla is able to sell so many vehicles
is thanks to their cheaper model 3 and
why throughout all of 2021 tesla only
delivered roughly 25 000 s's and x's
this means that for it to make sense for
rivien to scale to 150 000 vehicles per
year they would have to sell six times
as many model s as the nexus as tesla
sold last year
i don't think that's an impossible goal
for rivien but that level of demand
doesn't just show up overnight it takes
years of deliveries brand building and
trust and to make things worse for
rivien it looks like we're heading into
a recession meaning that it's going to
be significantly harder to sell luxury
vehicles even if we don't enter a
recession it doesn't really matter
because the fear of entering one has
already set in and this will no doubt
cause people to think twice before
buying a 70 000 pickup truck fortunately
rivien can at least slowly decrease
prices with the time as the production
process becomes more efficient which
will hopefully attract more customers
wait never mind they can't do that
either due to insane inflation and the
supply shortage which i made raw
materials and semiconductors extremely
expensive they already increased their
prices by 12 000 in march and this was
likely just the first of many to come
not only does this make it harder for
rivien to sell their vehicles but it
also makes it harder for them to scale
production even companies as established
as apollo are dealing with supply
constraints
so there's no doubt that supply
constraints will carry over to rivien as
well
aside from having to fight against the
legacy players and deal with killing
production rivien also has to deal with
abysmal financials now ravian's
valuation has come down substantially
and given how much cash they have the
intrinsic value of their vehicles and
their brand value i don't think their
current valuation out of 20 to 30
billion dollars is too crazy i mean
their total assets currently stands at
21 billion dollars so they're basically
just trading at book value clearly their
valuation isn't that bad compared to
their assets and brand value but their
valuation is still ridiculous compared
to their revenue and the net income
figures in the first quarter of 2022
rivian only pulled in 95 million worth
of revenue and to get this revenue it
cost them up 597 million dollars meaning
that their gross profit was negative
half a billion dollars tack on half a
billion dollars worth of r d and another
half a billion dollars worth of selling
general and administrative expenses and
you're left with a net loss of 1.593
billion dollars in a single quarter at
that rate rivien would have burned 316
billion cash reserves within a matter of
two and a half years fortunately their
financials should improve it with time
but i doubt they'll become profitable
anytime soon which means that they'll
have to raise money sooner or later and
in the current stock market environment
that's not exactly an easy task
rivien does have some notable backers
including ford and amazon but they're
not exactly doing well themselves in
fact amazon lost money on their retail
business last quarter and the loss on
ribbon just made their financial report
look even worse not to mention amazon
stock is down nearly 50 percent
meanwhile ford has been straight up
cashing out of their rivian position in
may ford sold off tens and millions of
shares of rivien which is not surprising
given that they themselves are fighting
for survival last quarter ford lost 3.1
billion dollars mostly because of rivien
and ford can't really afford this given
that they already have 207 billion
dollars worth of liabilities this isn't
to say that amazon and ford wouldn't
bail out rivien if they had to but i
don't think they particularly want to
this means that most of the losses would
have to be paid for by public stock
investors through share offerings if
you're not familiar with what a share
offering is it's when a company issues
new shares of their stock to raise money
and continue operations not only does
this dilute existing shareholders but it
adds significant amounts of selling
pressure into the market and there's
really no way around this for rivien to
achieve the economies of skill necessary
to become profitable they have to invest
heavily into r d and factories and
scaling production so riv unit is in for
years of substantial losses which just
makes it even harder for the stock to
gain any sort of bullish momentum
like many of my videos nowadays this
video hasn't exactly been kind to rivian
but this isn't to say that i don't like
the company or that they're gonna go
bankrupt rivien's r1t and r1s are
phenomenal vehicles and it's crazy to
think that a startup was able to produce
such high quality vehicles in the future
when wait times cool down i would
strongly consider rivien when purchasing
a vehicle for myself but while rivien
excites me as a customer it does not
excite me as an investment they have
several years of hardship ahead of them
and sky high inflation the supply
shortage and legacy players just make it
even harder for them to scale up and
achieve profitability and in a market
where all stocks are getting destroyed
there's plenty of options when it comes
to distressed talks and personally
rivien just doesn't strike me as the
best of those options but that's just
what i think would you guys rather buy a
tesla or a rivien comment that down
below also drop a like if you're glad
that bubble valuations are finally
coming back down to earth and of course
consider checking out our discord
community to suggest future video ideas
and consider subscribing and see more
questions logically answered but until
then i'm hurry and i'll see you guys on
the next one